how's it going everybody so everybody
thought that the new Deadpool movie
which is a pg-13 version of Deadpool 2
was going to be called a Deadpool before
Christmas well it turns out that's not
the case this new version that comes out
in December got an official title and an
official logo today this was confirmed
by deadlines official Twitter page as
they tweeted out the title and the logo
not only did we get the official title
and logo today but we also got a little
bit more insight on why Fox and Ryan
Reynolds are doing a pg-13 version of
Deadpool turns out that the pg-13
version is for a good cause charity
$1.00 of every ticket sold will go to
the fudge cancer charity and apparently
Fox has wanted a pg-13 version of the
movie since 2006 for their younger
viewers Ryan Reynolds says Fox has been
asking for a pg-13 basically since the
start in 2006 I've said no since 2006
now this one time I said yes on two
conditions
first a portion of the proceeds had to
go to charity second I wanted to kidnap
Fred Savage this second condition took
some explaining so the pg-13 version of
Deadpool 2 will have 15 minutes of new
footage never seen before
most likely including the kidnapping of
Fred Savage and the movie will only be
in theaters from December 12th to
Christmas Eve so if you want go see it
while you have the chance that's it for
this update on once upon a Deadpool let
me know what you think about this in the
comments below and I'm still doing my
giveaway giving away copies of Infinity
Ward Deadpool 2 and ant-man on the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you